[Music]
on this Monday night Toronto's top cop
quits
the surprise announcement from mark
Saunders I'll be free agent well across
Canada and the u.s. calls to defund
police forces gain traction
what it could mean anger from migrant
agricultural workers Canada relies on he
said you should go home if we don't like
you the appalling conditions and the
hazards they say they face from Kovac
nineteen positive news during the
pandemic white New Zealand has reason to
celebrate and the mystery of an ancient
treasure chest unlocked the unfindable
has been found a single secret left in a
million-dollar mystery
[Music]
verbal national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with big developments related
to the police in the u.s. and here in
Canada the calls for change and how the
police operate and for black lives to
matter have never been louder now calls
to defund police are gaining traction -
that doesn't mean dismantling police
forces completely but reallocating a
chunk of their funding - housing health
care and education things that won't
make life in marginalized communities
better and in Toronto the police chief
mark Saunders surprised everyone when he
announced he's leaving Saunders a 35
year veteran of the force became the
first black police chief of the Toronto
Police Service in 2015 on Friday he took
a knee in the protests tweeting we see
you and we are listening we have to all
stay in this together to make change he
says he's leaving with a heavy heart but
wants to put his family first in our top
story tonight Eric Sorenson looks at
Saunders departure and the broader
debate about the future of policing and
it's time to say thank you Toronto it
was a shock and keep Toronto Police
Chief Mark Saunders announcing he'll
step down the end of next month it comes
at a time of massive protests accusing
police departments across North America
of racism and brutality towards black
people Saunders who took a knee in
solidarity with marchers last week says
family was his main consideration in
leaving but he cautions against mounting
calls to defund Police Department's if
we get it right then there needs to be
other agencies that satisfy the needs of
the community in the absence of that
things will not work it's as simple as
that activists say they are underserved
and over policed we're the last
generation that's gonna stand for this
it's spurring debates to reimagine
public safety so police are not the
primary response to incidents such as
homelessness or mental health those are
individuals that are better in the hands
of other service providers that the city
and the province can can offer it means
that we want a healthy safe response to
so that black people don't end up dead
because they ask for help
the prime minister said Ottawa is always
reviewing how public dollars are spent
on policing and promises specific action
on police body cameras and I will
certainly be talking about the province
with the provinces and premiers about
the need to move forward on measures
like body cameras the urgency to act
follows the death of George Floyd while
being arrested by Minneapolis police two
weeks ago
the City Council there has pledged to
dismantle its police department to end
policing as we know it but for the US
president widely criticized for his
response to protesters defunding police
gives him a new argument for law and
order
you eliminate police officers you will
have chaos crime in anarchy in the
streets and that's something that's
unacceptable to the president back in
Canada the departing Toronto Police
Chief says his work will not be finished
when he leaves his job I see a lot of
young black boys getting killed by young
black boys law enforcement deals with
those symptoms and I want to help the
cure for the disease I'm Eric Sorenson
global news Toronto's that can help when
Mark Saunders took the job he was just
the second black police chief in
Canada's history
he served through two horrific attacks
in that city in April 2018 when 10
people were killed when a van plowed
down pedestrians on Yonge Street and
three months later a mass shooting on
Toronto's popular Danforth Avenue left
two people dead and more than a dozen
injured Saunders faced controversy over
his department's handling of several
missing men connected to Toronto's gay
village and concerns they were victims
of a serial murder police later linked
the disappearances of eight men to Bruce
MacArthur who was convicted of their
murders in 2019 the news of Saunders
departure comes at a time of turmoil
across the continent there's outrage
over systemic racism and policing after
the death of George Floyd today the now
former Minneapolis officer charged with
his death made his first court
appearance
Derek Chauvin who was caught on video
pinning Floyd down with a knee on his
neck faces up to 40 years in prison if
convicted he's been charged with second
degree murder and second-degree
manslaughter the judge in the case has
set Chauvin bail at 1.25 million dollars
three other former officers accused of
aiding and abetting Floyd's death had
bail set at seven hundred and fifty
thousand dollars as Chauvin appeared in
court hundreds of mourners lined up in
Floyd's hometown of Houston Texas today
to pay their respects this will be the
third and final memorial before George
Floyd is buried tomorrow the governor of
Texas a Republican was among the first
at the public viewing of Floyd's gold
casket George Floyd was going to change
the Ark of the future of the United
States George Floyd has not died in vain
his life will be a living legacy there
are signs the death of George Floyd may
truly be a turning point in the u.s. as
Jackson prosecco reports more and more
political leaders are making commitments
to change in this moment of change
barriers have become monuments outside
the White House a three meter high
security fence added amidst the protests
is today covered in calls to address
racial injustice while inside the US
Capitol Democrats paused for 8 minutes
and 46 seconds of silence before
announcing a bill to reform policing in
America never again should the world be
subjected to witnessing what we saw on
the streets in Minneapolis the slow
murder of an individual by a uniformed
police officer it all marks a
long-awaited turning point for many
Americans Minneapolis has voted to
disband its local police department New
York home to the largest police force in
the country is vowing changes to it
takes in New York City too long for
there to be accountability for officers
who do the wrong thing for the first
time in a generation public opinion is
overwhelmingly on the side of those
calling for reform by a margin of two to
one Americans are more troubled by the
actions of police in the death of George
Floyd than they are by the resulting
protests that turned violent 57 percent
of Americans believe police are more
like
excessive force against black Americans
up from just 33% from six years ago
after Eric garner died at the hands of
New York City police it feels like I get
to be a part of history and a part of
the group of people who are trying to
change the world the police brutality
experienced by those protesting that
very issue may have helped turn the tide
scenes of tear gas and pepper spray
deployed against peaceful demonstrators
have fueled the calls for lasting change
so to have images like these the latest
accusation of excessive force a police
officer in Virginia is now charged with
assault after tasing and striking a man
who reportedly told first responders he
needed to detox Jackson prosto Global
News Washington
Alberta's police watchdog says two RCMP
officers have been charged with criminal
negligence related to a 20-18 shooting
and the death of a 31 year old man and
in another case shown on this video
three RCMP officers in Prince George BC
are charged with assault related to an
arrest in February of 2016
one officer faces charges of assault
with a weapon and obstruction while two
other officers have been charged with
assault causing bodily harm now to the
other big story we continue to follow
the pandemic several provinces are
lifting more public health restrictions
in Newfoundland and Labrador outdoor
pools camping day camps retail stores
and restaurants are back in business
with restrictions some team sports can
also resume as well as services at
private health clinics and salons
Saskatchewan is lifting its
non-essential travel ban in the north
while restaurants across the province
can reopen at 50% capacity daycares and
places of worship are also reopening
with restrictions and in Quebec today
movie and TV production can resume as
well as team sports all with some
physical distancing and hygiene
restrictions in place and starting on
Friday parts of Ontario will move to
stage two of reopening there but not in
the Greater Toronto and Hamilton regions
they still have the highest
concentration of Ontario's Cove in 19
cases we will continue talking to local
officials who are playing a critical
role in determining what areas can open
and I am confident that the rest of the
province will get the stage to very very
soon Stage two allows for outdoor dining
camping and gatherings up to ten people
will also be allowed some salon and
retail services are also opening with
restrictions the canada-us border has
been closed to non-essential travel for
over two and a half months now the
Canadian government is allowing family
members who were separated in that
process to reunite an exemption will
begin at midnight two foreign nationals
who are immediate family members of
Canadian citizens and permanent
residents family members will be defined
as spouses or common-law partners
dependent children and parents or legal
guardians anyone wanting to enter the
country from the US cannot have Cobin 19
or be showing any symptoms they'll also
be required to quarantine for 14 days
once they arrive in Canada Canada also
had travel exemptions in place for
temporary foreign workers who were vital
to many industries here particularly in
the agriculture sector Canada usually
brings in as many as 60,000 seasonal
agricultural workers every year through
the temporary foreign workers program
they live and work in close quarters and
Kovach 19 outbreaks have led to two
deaths of migrant workers in Canada as
Michael Okakura reports there are
troubling signs many are not being
properly taken care of this is like
Martinez Martinez leaving a temporary
foreign worker gives a shocking account
of conditions where he works we've
agreed to hide his identity because he's
worried speaking out will get him fired
but he's speaking to Global News because
going to the farmer got him nowhere he
said we should get home if we if we if
we don't like it
and he's been doing this for many many
years the migrant workers Alliance for
Change says they've had thousands of
other complaints just like that
the group's new report chronicles issues
on farms that they say I've gone
unchecked for years to temporary foreign
workers recently died of kovat 19 two
more are in intensive care and advocates
say issues have been exacerbated by the
Panda
there's rats living in their oven
cramped um bedrooms just really
conditions that are really unsafe and
not not healthy for anyone all temporary
foreign workers were supposed to be
quarantined when they arrived in Canada
but some say they were still sleeping in
bunk beds in BC workers were sent to
self isolate in hotels paid for by the
province New Brunswick had banned
temporary foreign workers but reversed
that decision because agriculture and
seafood producers were unable to find
enough local laborers advocates had
asked the federal government to make
temporary foreign workers permanent
residents so they'd have the same rights
as Canadian workers Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau wouldn't respond to that
directly whether they're permanent
residents or whether they're simply
temporary foreign workers we need to do
a better job of protecting temporary
agricultural workers in this country a
promise to do more but not the
improvements to health and safety being
demanded by workers who are a key part
of Canada's agricultural sector Michael
cooter Global News Ottawa there are new
details on the deadly crash of a
Canadian Armed Forces helicopter off the
coast of Greece the cyclone helicopter
was deployed with the Navy frigate HM CS
Fredericton as part of a NATO mission
when it crashed into the Ionian Sea on
April 29th in an initial report released
today the Department of National Defense
says the aircraft did not respond as the
crew would have anticipated during what
it calls a complex maneuver as it
approached the ship the report says the
crew could not recover at the low
altitude and the aircraft then entered a
high-energy descent and impacted the
water the investigation will continue to
look at the aircraft systems and any
human factors all six service members on
board died Global News has learned the
RCMP will include in cells in its
terrorism awareness guide just weeks
after the first ever terror charge was
laid in connection to the online
movement the insel is described as one
of the most dangerous subcultures as
Abigail Beeman reports RCMP aimed to
prevent further attacks in
linked to the extremist ideology police
laid the first-ever terrorism charges
linked to the insel movement a couple of
weeks ago after a murder in Toronto
involuntary celibates gained wider
attention after the 2018 van attack in
the same city
now Global News has learned in cells
will be added to the RCMP s Terrorism
guide currently undergoing an update
there's a really critical piece of
public communications from the RCMP
taking you know really two years at
least to include install and the inside
ideology in this guide is surprising
it's part of a broader recognition I
believe of the the kinds of threats that
are posed around terrorism
aside from Islamist inspired hate and
extremism expert Barbara parry says
while the number of in cells who are
violent may be small the narratives are
dangerous so what's an appropriate
response then if you can't get a date
right if women aren't attracted to you
well violence is an appropriate response
and you know we know how high the rate
of violence against women is anyway and
you add this permission if you will and
I think it's a it's a risk that we need
to take seriously we recognize that it's
both a public safety but also a public
health crisis moonshot CBE is studying
in cells and their presence in this
country it's been given nearly half a
million dollars from Public Safety
Canada to do it and already produced
this primer of their own
it's tempting not to take it seriously
on one level the the feelings that a lot
of these individuals have it are easy to
ridicule frankly and a lot of people
have but that only makes the problem
worse in addition to the upcoming move
by the RCMP CSIS noted in cells in a
recent public report another example of
agencies recognizing broader terrorism
threats abigail Beeman global news
Ottawa anti racism protesters take
matters into their own hands coming up
the statue of a slave owner that came
tumbling down in England
the calls for an end to racial
inequality are reverberating well beyond
the US huge rallies in the UK this
weekend were peaceful apart from some
violent flashes in the city of Bristol a
statue of a slave trader was toppled and
as crystal commencing reports it's
calling into question who we choose to
celebrate a firestorm of reaction after
protesters of all colors topple the
statue of Edward Colston I think that it
has been idolized for far too long in
this city well I think that is utterly
disgraceful and that speaks to the acts
of disorder public disorder
Poston was a 17th century merchant who
made a fortune buying transporting and
selling people on Sunday people took
turns rolling his bronze statue down the
street then hurled it into the harbor
police were there but didn't step in he
made a very tactical decision that to
stop people from doing that act may have
caused further disorder and we decided
the safest piece to do in terms of our
peace and tactics was tonight to take
place an official investigation has been
launched but the mayor doesn't appear to
be troubled by what happened
but being thrown in the harbor and I
almost missed a piece of historical
poetry where you know a man who
undoubtedly had slaves thrown off his
ships during the passage at some point
ended up underwater
there are several petitions calling for
a statue of a prominent black figure to
be erected where Colston's
stood for 125 years seems such a
formidable presence and yet the lifting
of it and even it just seemed quite
effortless the Colston statue will be
retrieved from the water and likely put
into a museum
crystal commencing Global News London
still ahead no cases no worries the
corona virus is eradicated in New
Zealand
once the epicenter of America's kovat 19
outbreak New York City entered phase one
of its reopening plan today 100 days
after the first case the infection rate
is declining about 400,000 people headed
back to work and non-essential
businesses like retail and construction
sites but with limited operations some
retailers are waiting for tensions over
the death of George Floyd two E's and
many stores in the city remain closed
New Zealand is another matter the Prime
Minister there lifted all kovat 19
restrictions today in the country has
been declared virus-free I I did a
little dance
Jacinda our turn is being praised for
locking down New Zealand early on March
25th and getting the public a clear path
out of the pandemic there's no more
physical distancing all schools and
workplaces are open the border is closed
to foreigners though our durn has warned
New Zealand will certainly see new cases
again when that changes brazil's
government has removed months of
critical data from its Kovan 19 tracking
website the move is adding to calls the
president is trying to cover up the true
scale of the crisis the country
originally logged all cases of kovat 19
and deaths and gave specific data for
the country's 27 states and
municipalities now it's only showing the
number of kovat 19 cases recorded in the
last 24 hours
next discovering the unexpected rewards
from one man's modern-day treasure hunt
over ten years ago a wealthy art dealer
buried two million dollars worth of
treasure somewhere in the Rocky
Mountains of New Mexico and put out
tantalizing clues in a poem begin it
where warm waters halt and take it in
the canyon down not far but too far to
walk
well now someone has finally cracked
those clues and found the treasure
Robin Gill reports deep in the Rocky
Mountains in Santa Fe New Mexico there
really was a treasure at the end of the
rainbow a 13th century bronze chest
filled with gold and gems worth an
estimated two million dollars Forrest
Fenn an antiques collector hid the
treasure more than a decade ago well I
made it heard deliberately if it was
easy anyone could do it the clues were
in a poem he wrote from there is no
place for the make the end is ever
drawing that someone picked up on the
lines of verse and found the location
the modern day Indiana Jones who wants
to remain anonymous sent Fenn a picture
of his newfound wealth scarf Wrangler
treasure then wanted to tempt people
into the wilderness which he says is the
real reward hundreds tried including the
harp family it didn't lead to riches but
that didn't matter and it gave us a
perspective of the world our children
still five people lost their lives on
this expedition Fenn sorry they died but
insisted it wasn't dangerous the
treasure is not hidden in a mine a lot
of these old mines are dangerous what
was his secret is now someone else's and
that lucky anonymous individual is the
new mystery Robin Gill global news and
that is global national for this Monday
I'm donor freezin tonight's here Canada
is this beautiful garden in Spencer
Smith Park in Burlington Ontario thanks
for watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye bye
[Music]
[Applause]